today's episode is brought to you by
skillshare
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
what do lasik surgeries and gps have in
common how is cloud computing connected
to invisible braces
did you know that scratch resistant
lenses were related to dust busters
actually all of these things have nasa
to credit for their existence
yes from the scratch resistant lenses in
your glasses to lasik surgery that rids
you of those very glasses
all are products of technologies
developed by the national aeronautics
and space administration
or nasa as we call it contrary to
popular belief
that nasa is all about sending rovers to
other planets and getting beautiful
pictures
in reality the space agency is a part of
our daily lives and we don't even
realize it
still the primary job of nasa is the
exploration of the universe
a lot of you have probably seen the
recent images of the mars rover landing
getting the craft to land on mars was
hard but it's exponentially more
difficult
to send humans into space and getting
them back is even more difficult
radiation and absence of oxygen and
water escaping the earth's gravity
and re-entering the earth's atmosphere
are all factors that make space travel
extremely perilous now
imagine the scale of a disaster if an
accident takes place in the void of
space
human lives will be lost in the vast
emptiness forever
this almost happened half a century ago
in april of 1970 on apollo 13.
what followed though is a marvelous
story of human grit
undeterred resolve on the spot
innovation and
unshakable perseverance a true story
that is comparable to any edge of your
seat
sci-fi thriller you are watching cold
fusion tv
[Music]
in the early 1960s when the soviets
seemed to be winning the space race by
first sending a dog
and later a man by the name of yuri
gagarin to space
the then u.s president john f kennedy
challenged america to the ultimate goal
to put a man on the moon by the end of
the decade
the dream was fulfilled when neil
armstrong stepped on the moon on july
20th
1969 for the apollo 11 mission earlier
the apollo 7 8 9 and 10 missions had
been sent to the moon
but none of them involved a human
landing on the lunar surface
with apollo 13 nasa wanted to land
astronauts in the framaro area of the
moon
this is a geologically tougher landing
site and is supposed to have been formed
by asteroid impact
the apollo 13 mission the mission setup
of the craft was in three parts
the cone-shaped command module where the
three men would be for most of the trip
the spider-like lunar module that would
carry two of the three astronauts to the
moon
and lastly the service module it was a
large cylindrical craft
with the main engines and oxygen tanks
during the mission the service module
would orbit the moon
and rejoin with a jettisoned capsule
that blasted off from the lunar module
after the moonwalk was complete
this all had to be perfectly timed a
feed done by two on-board guidance
computers
one in the orbiting command module and
the other in the lunar module
like the previous two apollo missions
the crew consisted of three men
mission commander james lovell father of
four and highly experienced
command module pilot john swiggett a
last minute step in for another
astronaut who had been exposed to the
measles
and lastly lunar module pilot fred hayes
a rookie who left his wife and three
kids on earth
for a mission being so interesting no
one showed much interest when apollo 13
took flight
at 2 37 p.m eastern standard time on
april 11th
1970. in three and a half days the trio
would be walking on the moon
perhaps by now the last two apollo
missions made a walk on the moon
seem more like a walk in the park even
the live telecast of the crew flying
through space all the way to the moon
wasn't broadcast by major networks but
little did anyone know
that within 10 minutes of the completion
of the broadcast something would happen
that would peak the interest of the
entire world but for now
things were going well
while traveling at about 40 000
kilometers per hour the crew would
perform an 180 degree turn
to dock the lunar module and leave the
spent main rocket behind
they were now on their way to the moon
[Music]
everything was going smoothly quote
we're bored to tears down here
said joe the capsule communicator at 46
hours and 43 minutes
but unbeknownst to the crew just a few
meters below where they sat
there were some cracked wires next to a
highly flammable oxygen tank
at 55 hours and 46 minutes the crew
finished the tv broadcast
in which the rookie fred hayes pulled a
few practical jokes on his crew
his favorite was to push the
repressurization valve which produces a
large banging noise
they were now 322 000 kilometers away
from earth
four-fifths of the way to the moon
at around this time jack turned on the
fans to stare oxygen tanks one and two
in the service module
unfortunately for all on board the
cracked wires were now exposed
tank number two exploded with a bang
they all looked at each other thinking
fred hayes was playing another prank
but this time fred was just as stunned
as the other two
at this moment the master alarm light
and an electrical power failure warning
was
triggered
houston we have a problem here these
were the famous words that mission
commander james lovell
reported to mission control
meanwhile down on earth mission control
couldn't believe what they were seeing
the warning lights indicated the loss of
two of three fuel cells
they were the spacecraft's primary
source of electricity
they realized that one oxygen tank was
completely empty and the oxygen in the
second tank was depleting
the engineers at mission control were
scrambling to figure out what was wrong
there couldn't possibly be this many
failures at once or the crew would be
dead
this is you fall back upon your
simulation training
and you start working the problem and
you work at the best you can
i was thinking that it was solvable
and then i was coming to conclusion that
i couldn't solve it
and that wasn't a good feeling but to
the dismay of the engineers monitoring
on earth the catastrophic failures were
confirmed within a few minutes
and quite horrifyingly so
when james lovell happened to glance out
the left window he could see a gas
leaking it was the oxygen from the
second
and the only remaining tank at this
moment
the crew knew that they were in big
trouble
amazingly they didn't panic as they knew
that that would solve nothing we never
panicked and and people often ask me why
we never panicked and
the fact is we could have bounced off
the walls for about 10 minutes
and when we finished we'd be back where
we started from as the crew
watched their precious oxygen leak out
they realized that they would lose all
oxygen
and soon subsequently their last fuel
cell
they were now without electricity light
and water
200 000 miles away from earth and still
traveling
rapidly in the wrong direction landing
on the moon was out of the question now
the first thing they had to do was
correct their trajectory
the explosion had shifted them off
course and if they didn't correct
they would still swing around the moon
but upon their return
they would miss the earth completely as
the disaster unfolded the news media
began picking up the story
from abc news space headquarters
there has been an emergency flight of
apollo 13
some kind of explosion occurred in the
spacecraft's main engine
the explosion affected the spacecraft's
main power system supplied by fuel cells
and that means that their oxygen supply
is in jeopardy and their water supply is
officially turned
critical the whole earth was now
watching including the families of those
in space
i thought to myself something's wrong
you know my dad's never coming back i'm
never going to see my dad again
and you know he's basically you know i
basically felt at that point that he was
dead
with no propulsion possible from the
damaged service module
at one hour and 29 seconds after the
explosion the decision was made from the
monitoring engineers on the ground that
the crew should use the lunar module as
a lifeboat
it wasn't going to be easy though how
would the oxygen supply be maintained
what would happen when power runs out
was there enough food on the lunar
module
what about water how was the crew going
to navigate back to earth
all systems in the command module except
the critical ones had to be shut down in
order to conserve power
this would drop the temperature inside
the craft to below freezing
and they didn't know if the guidance
instruments could take that cold
temperature
the guidance system is like your eyes
and your foot on the throttle and your
hands on the steering wheel
it's the information that gives you the
ability
to if you will steer from one point to
another
and so the question was would be
instruments you'll be able to take the
cold temperature
with only 15 minutes of power and oxygen
left in the damaged service module
they all made their way to the lunar
module thankfully in all of this
there was one bright spot surplus oxygen
in the lunar module
but only for a while it wasn't an ideal
situation
but it was going to have to do the lamb
was a
flimsy looking spidery type vehicle
the crew compartment had no amenities
whatsoever it didn't even have seats
the skin of the crew compartment was
about 12
thousandths of an inch thick aluminum
that would be like
three layers of reynolds wrap put
together
you could easily if you were careless
put your your boot or your foot
right through that wall
yes that's right if someone moved their
foot the wrong way
it could puncture the craft and their
oxygen could escape and they'd all die
meanwhile on the ground the
manufacturers of the lunar module
were hard at work calculating how long
it could support the life of three
people instead of two
as it had originally been designed they
calculated
two days but how long would it take for
them to get home
nobody knew yet so the main question
still remained
how do you bring the three men back home
[Music]
they had two options the crew could use
the main engine to try and get back to
earth as quickly as possible
but run the risk of engine failure or
they could take an extra one to two days
to use the moon's gravity
and fling them back towards earth they
decided to go for the second option
they were going to go around the moon
this involved using the lunar modules
rocket which was never designed for this
purpose but even less so
with the command module still attached
the center of gravity was now
completely off so the controls no longer
corresponded to the inputs given
if you tried to turn left it would pitch
up or if you tried pitching down
it would go to the right it was like
flying a fighter jet but with all the
control labels switched
they had no choice but to try
a 35 second rocket burn was carried out
to speed up the craft
but the calculations made back on earth
said that they would run out of power
and water before coming home
they needed more speed but how were they
going to figure out how to get up to
speed
the onboard computer was very primitive
for context
this was a year before intel had
invented the cpu microprocessor
the apollo computer could only store a
few thousand numbers in ram
and its power was orders of magnitude
less than even a basic nokia phone from
decades ago
because of this reason all the
calculations had to be done on the
ground
and the instructions radioed back about
when to fire the rocket at exactly what
power level
and for how long the crew had to copy
the instructions precisely
before they lost radio contact when they
traveled behind the moon
the calculations suggested that a burn
of 5 minutes would cut 24 hours off the
travel time
but it might not have been enough after
the first hour or so as we began to
gather the data
and we saw those data points you know
heading down
it became obvious that within you know
an
hour so that we weren't going to make it
at that rate the biggest power consumer
on the learner module is the guidance
system
merit feels it's essential to turn it
off but lonnie and krantz fuel just as
strongly it has to stay
up and running so the crew can position
the ship glenn
if we don't get this thing powered down
uh we're not going to make it
and of course glenn uh was receptive and
i said well let's see your data you know
once you looked at the data
and and the data was coming in you know
it was obvious we weren't going to make
it
they decided to leave the guidance
computer on for now and then turn
everything off and float to earth
in below freezing temperatures for three
days
to conserve water the crew had to cut
down their intake to about a fifth of
normal
worse they were requested to not eject
urine into space so they wouldn't
disturb the flight's trajectory
this meant that the crew had to store
their waste in bags and practically
stopped drinking water
they became dehydrated cold sleep
deprived
and fred hayes developed a bladder
infection and then a fever
the other two crew members would wrap
their bodies around him to keep him warm
they were miserable
by now the entire world was following
the updates of apollo 13.
if i may be serious for one moment and
ask
the entire audience for a moment
of prayer for the crew men
of the apollo 13 we'll hold silence for
a moment please
countries offered help and people across
the globe prayed
the world watched as a dangerous
adventure unfolded
an adventure that wouldn't be paralleled
by any other in years to come
but even so there were even more
problems
the three men were creating excess
carbon dioxide that needed to be
expelled or they'd suffocate
the lunar module was running out of
carbon dioxide filters but the command
module had plenty of spares
the only issue was that the openings of
the two filters were not compatible
so everyone had to get creative the
problem was that we had these
square canisters and in the lunar module
the receptacle in which you put the co2
filters was round
because the lunar module uses used round
canisters or filters instead of square
ones so our problem was how do we
connect this square canister
to a system that will only accept round
filters with at least two more days of
the journey still left the challenge
however was that mission control could
only build prototypes and the actual
method had to be built by the crew
as per the instructions from the ground
even just describing the contraption was
hard
thankfully the crew managed to do so
using plastic bags
cardboard and duct tape
even after solving the problems of power
water
food and excess carbon dioxide the
biggest challenge
still remained getting back to earth
the touchdown was planned for the
pacific but the craft could land in an
unspecified range of hundreds of miles
re-entry itself was a gamble coming home
from the moon you had to come in and hit
the atmosphere
in a reentry quarter that was only two
degrees
wide a pie shaped wedge not any less
than five and a half degrees
not any greater than seven and a half
degrees you had to come down that two
degree wedge
if you came in too shallow you'd skip
out like skipping a stone on water
if you came in too steep all that sudden
deceleration would make you a
fiery meteor over the sky for a few
brief seconds
because they were coming in too shallow
and the guidance computer was still
powered off
the crew needed to course correct by
hand they had to line up the earth in
the center of their window
and hope for the best i know that when
that engine goes on
that i'll never be able to keep the
earth in the window
by myself because these are what we call
three attitude
attitude controllers and pitch and roll
and y'all
i said you take your attitude controller
and keep the area from going back and
forth too much
i'll keep i'll take my attitude
controller and keep the earth from going
up and down too much
he said fine and then over on the side i
had a couple of buttons
uh one said start and one said stop
these were buttons that directly
connected the battery
to the decent engine the one and only
time they were ever used
in the apollo program at the proper time
jack said start
i hit the start button the engine went
on
14 seconds later jack said stop i hit
the stop button
and in between that time we juggled the
earth you know up and down and sideways
and then of course we waited
the last challenge was to move back to
the frozen command module and power up
its controls before the final flight to
earth
this required the creation of new
methods these methods would usually take
months to be created but they were
devised in three straight days by flight
controllers under the guidance of flight
director gene krantz
the team on the ground were doing some
of the most consequential engineering
under a lot of pressure every
calculation had to be just right
[Music]
with nine hours to go before re-entry
they were traveling at thirty-two
thousand kilometres an hour
or twenty 000 miles per hour the crew
wrote the instructions on whatever scrap
pieces of paper that they could find on
board
this takes over two hours we knew early
in the
game that the power down levels would
approach survival
of the crew and the survival of the
system the systems would get so cold
that we were worried that possibly the
batteries might freeze the propellant
and the command and service module lines
would freeze
there was a good chance we would get the
combined spacecraft home but when we
brought up the
command and service module it would be
non-functional it was the end of the
road
but to everyone's relief as the crew
threw the switches to power up the
command module
everything booted up the components had
withstood the cold temperatures
far beyond their design limits the crew
jettisoned the service module
as the service module drifted away for
the first time
they could see the true extent of the
disaster the whole side had been blown
off in the explosion
but now there was another risk there was
a possibility that their heat shield
could have been affected by the
explosion
if it was damaged in any way it was
likely that they would burn up in the
atmosphere
but the crew couldn't think about that
right now as they had to jettison their
lunar module lifeboat
it was time for re-entry the flight
finally entered the earth's atmosphere
a communications blackout was supposed
to last for three minutes as they turned
into a glowing orb in the sky
when the blackout didn't end after that
everybody monitoring on earth became
extremely anxious
it was looking like the crew had
perished upon re-entry
then suddenly the words ok joe were
heard
after they crossed through the
atmosphere the crew deployed their
parachutes successfully
they had done it a huge sigh of relief
could be felt by all
finally they splashed down in the
pacific ocean on april 17th
after 142 hours 54 minutes
and 41 seconds of a perilous journey all
three flight members got home safe and a
million prayers from around the globe
had been answered
the apollo 13 accident review board
investigated the disaster
and later identified the reason being a
short circuit it was discovered that
when fuel tank number one was modified
to be fitted in the apollo 13
spaceflight
the voltage to the heaters in the oxygen
tanks were raised from 28 volts to 65
volts dc unfortunately
the thermostatic switches on the heaters
weren't modified to suit the change
the final test on the launch pad damaged
the teflon insulation on the tank
leading to the risk of a short circuit
which in turn caused the explosion
the command module is now kept in the
kansas cosmosphere and space center in
kansas
while the lunar module is believed to
have burned up in the earth's atmosphere
the three crew members didn't get a
chance to land on the moon again
but mission commander james lovell
became the first person to travel to the
moon twice
even though apollo 13 couldn't complete
its mission of landing on the moon
it's called a successful failure a
successful failure
because nasa managed to bring the entire
crew safely back to earth on a damaged
spacecraft
the mission gave several lessons to the
space agency in terms of engineering and
spacecraft design this ensured
future successes of polar missions the
story of apollo 13
showcases the best of engineering and
thinking on one's feet
bringing three men back home from 200
000 miles out in space
is a story for all time
if you do enjoy this channel then i'm
sure you enjoy learning
and a great way to do that is skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes
it's a place where you can learn new
skills or develop existing interests
i'm currently enjoying the course
productivity for creatives
build a system that brings out your best
by thomas frank
one thing that stuck out to me was the
importance of having a professional
mindset
in creative work this simply means
putting systems in place
to get the work done in the course
thomas references an interesting quote
by the author james clear
quote you do not rise to the level of
your goals you fall to the level of your
systems
so whether it's launching men into outer
space or doing creative work at home
yeah it turns out that systems are
important
whether you're looking to fend off
boredom or focus on self-care through
creativity or just want to get more work
done
skillshare has you covered the first
1000 people to use the link in my
description
will get a free trial of skillshare
premium membership and after that
it's only around 10 a month so thank you
so much for watching
and also thanks for all the comments
from my podcast appearance that i linked
in the bottom of the last episode they
all really mean a lot
so next on the channel i have some
interesting stuff coming up such as the
origins of bitcoin
and also what all the fuss is between
the australian government and big tech
so stay tuned for that anyways my name
is de gogo
and you've been watching cold fusion
feel free to follow me on instagram and
twitter
and i'll see you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys
have a good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]
you